Edward Snowden just got given Russian
citizenship what do you think I
understand the debate out there right
now Russia just granted him citizenship
which shows that he is serving the
Russian interests but regardless what
Snowden did by whistleblowing on the
Patriot Act and the collection against
U.S citizens he stole a bunch of other
compartmented secrets that had nothing
to do with that and he kept those as
like a just in case insurance policy he
also compromised those secrets that had
nothing to do with collections what
would the second sets he stole a lot of
those remain classified but the fact
that he stole those and downloaded those
and continued to use those as chip if
you go back and you look at snowden's
history he moved from place to place
from Hong Kong to Ecuador to Russia and
every time he just gave a little bit
more he kind of bought his next airplane
ticket if you will with a new secret and
that's the piece that makes people so
upset that's what technically makes him
a wanted man in the United States